- I'm a Pisces.
- Oh is it, when's your birthday?
- 23rd of February--
- Me being like, exposing
myself as somebody who's like,
"Oh, I love horoscopes, I'm a Scorpio."
- Are you, oh so you're a water sign?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're supposed to get on.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- For sure.
I get that though.
- Yeah, yippy!
(Gena and Little laugh)
- Hi I'm Gena, I'm here with
musician and actor Little Simz,
who plays Shelly in Top Boy,
and these are her Netflix IX.
What is is like starring in a show that is
so big, so important to the culture,
something that I assume
you may have watched
when you were like in school or whatever?
- Yeah.
- What's it Like?
- Sureal.
This is something I use to
want when I was younger.
And just remember feeling like,
finally, there's something on television
that represented us our our story,
and you know, our culture.
And add six years on to be a part of that.
Blessed to be a part of it, for sure.
- What was your reaction
when you got the call
about like, okay, come
be in Top Boy (mumbles)?
- Um, biggest smile on my face.
And like I'm a smiler,
but when I got this news
it's like, my cheeks were high,
and I just couldn't contain my excitement.
Straight away, called my mom.
- Yeah.
Tell my sisters, tell my brother,
and just everyone was super-happy.
- In Top Boy, you play Shelly.
- Mm hm.
- What drew you to the role,
and without any spoilers,
what can the audiences look forward to
in terms of that character?
- Her independence, her ambition,
her fight, and wanting to do more,
be better regardless of you know,
the environment she came from,
the circumstances she
circumstances she grew up in.
- Yeah.
- The last seasons,
you didn't really see
like a female perspective.
It was always like, very
from the guy's perspective.
And I think these boys, they have moms,
they've got sisters,
they've got girlfriends.
Their decisions and what they
choose to do affects also.
So I think what's great
about this new season
is you get to see it from
that female perspective.
- So when it comes to your acting,
did you always know that
you wanted to do acting?
Did that come hand-in-hand with
you realizing that you wanted to do music?
- Yeah, for sure, it's...
I started acting like before
I even got into music.
- Okay.
Anything within the performing
arts I just naturally gravitated towards.
So parts and things, it didn't feel alien.
It didn't feel foreign.
It felt like making that
switch between the two
didn't feel like a challenge to me.
Sometimes musicians or artist,
like when they get a role for something,
they bring their whole
artistry to, like the role.
- Yeah.
- And I think it's important
to separate the two.
- Get you a girl that can do
both, 'cause you can (mumbles).
(Little laughs)
- Okay let's talk
about inspiration: Who's
your biggest inspiration,
or one of your biggest inspirations
that comes to creating?
- For sure, it would be Lauryn Hill.
- Ooh, that's a really good choice.
- Mm hm, killed it with acting and is a
very rare talented artist, writer,
and she just does it well,
you know what I'm saying?
I know what it feels like,
when you see her in Sister Act,
of course, that's Lauryn Hill.
But there's also a very
talented actor, a star--
- Absolutely, I almost
like, sometimes don't
even connect the two,
because she's so...yeah.
- Right, right, but I think that's great.
And it's like, it's been a very big
inspiration for me for sure.
- All right, if I were to describe you,
I'd say your demeanor is
very cool, calm, collected.
Opposite of mine, which is less chill.
Um, but if you were to sum
yourself up in three words,
what would those three words be?
How would you describe yourself?
- A thinker, compassionate, and ambitious.
- So let's go back to music a little bit.
Check that I've done my homework properly.
One of your first gigs was
at the O2 in Islington?
- Yeah.
- Right.
- What's been your
favorite gig of all time,
if that was kind of like the
foundation of it started--
- All time...
- Yeah.
- I done a lot of shows, you know?
- Yeah, because you're famous, but...
(Gena and Little laugh loudly)
- Em, that show, the
show you just mentioned,
The O2 Academy, because I was so young.
And I think getting on that stage,
and it all clicking, like yeah!
I'm meant to be doing this.
Fast forward, years later,
um Glastonbury this year.
- Ooh! Oh my gosh, I can't even imagine.
Woo!
Three people, dead or alive,
to go to dinner with; who
would they be, and why?
- Michelle Obama, Oprah,
and Bionce.
(Gena blows loudly)
- I'd just be serving.
(Little laughs)
And water? (mumbles)
(Gena laughs loudly)
- They're just really strong
powerful black women that I just
feel like I can learn so much from
and I just soak up everything I can
and ask as many questions,
and just gain knowledge.
- So you've had a really
massive yeah, I would say.
But I'm not trying to
put words in your mouth.
But it seems to me, massive!
So you're album was released
widespread, critical acclaimed.
They knew, they know about you.
They know about the talent,
you know what I mean?
They're sleeping, but they're
a little awake, right?
Um, and that's not more than enough.
Obviously, you're starring in Top Boy.
As I said, so important to the cultures.
Something that a lot of us
have watched when we were growing up.
Did you have any idea that 2019
was gonna be as intense as it is?
And do you find it overwhelming,
or is it like, "Yeah, this is that time?"
- I didn't have the greatest 2018,
and I think that sparked something in me.
And sometimes like, I think like sometimes
negativity like breeds positivity,
which is cool, but I definitely
didn't expect it to be this wild,
but I'm grateful, I'm very grateful.
- Yeah all right, so
I want to speak to you
about as a North Londoner, right?
You grew up in North London?
- Mm hm.
- North London trough and through.
I'm a South Londoner.
- Really?
- Yeah.
So if you were trying to convince me
to switch sides and convert
to the North London tribe,
even though that would never happen.
I promise, I'm still
loyal to South London.
How would you sell it to me?
- Do you know what?
It just feels like...very communal.
Like, everyone knows each other.
But the thing is that with South;
sought feels like, just very big.
- Yeah, and the transport
links are like, not as great.
(Gena laughs loudly)
- Right.
- We don't have a Tube really.
Yeah, yeah, okay.
- So that's the...
Okay, so of course, so
I think you'd be able
to get around quicker in North,
and things like, you
can walk places, and--
- So it's gonna be near London--
But I think, if you, you
know what I'm saying?
If you've grown up in South
your whole life, so...
- Yeah.
- I'm not moving to South.
- Okay.
(Gena laughs loudly)
- In no kinda way, but
just that knda way, but...
You know what I'm saying?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I get it.
- London as a whole
is a great place!
- I agree 100%
Simz, thank you so much for...
Sorry actually, with
official title: Little Simz.
(Little laughs)
- Nice.
- Thank you so much for chatting with me.
And this was your Netfiix IX.
- Um hm, thank you so much.
(mid-tempo techno music)